ANNAH MOYO: My name
is Annah Yvonne Moyo.
I am currently acting
executive director
at the Center for the Study of
Violence and Reconciliation.
CSVR in short based in
Johannesburg, South Africa.
I am a transitional
justice expert
and have worked extensively
on the African continent
on transitional justice issues
from addressing colonial era
legacies through
transitional justice,
addressing economic issues
through transitional justice,
but also addressing
some of the current
and emerging challenges
and issues in practice
through transitional justice.
LILIANE UMUBYEYI: Thank you
so much for taking the time
today to discuss with us.
Maybe before we start
with the main topic,
could you tell us what
is transitional justice?
I'm sure there are a
lot of people who don't
know what this term means.
ANNAH MOYO: Transitional
justice basically
refers to a set of measures
that include truth, reparations,
justice, and accountability and
guarantees of non recurrence
or conflict that are
aimed at addressing
the consequences of
conflict, consequences
of authoritarian rule,
and other incidents that
bring about gross
human rights violations
and other human
rights violations
and crimes in a particular
setting, be it a society,
a nation, a country,
or a region.
That is the simple definition
of transitional justice.
On the African
continent, for instance,
we have expanded this definition
to really also include
specific tenets
of transformation
or transformative
justice, so to speak.
So we are looking
at these measures,
including formal and non-formal
measures or mechanisms
also including traditional
justice mechanisms
to implemented the crown
together with formal justice
mechanisms to address
consequences of violence,
consequences of some
of the tendencies
and incidents in Africa,
including legacies
of Africa's brutal past to
ensure that we move away
from that history of
brutalization and violations
to economic transformation,
developmental justice,
and transformative justice.
LILIANE UMUBYEYI: And have
you used that framework
in the context of CSVR to
tackle the colonial crimes
or the legacies of colonialism
on the continent or somewhere
else in the world?
ANNAH MOYO: Indeed, Liliane.
We are using that framework to
address a number of occurrences
on the continent.
If you look at a
number of countries
on the African continent,
some of the conflicts
that we are experiencing
currently really
stem from some of the
unresolved issues of the past.
The colonial era
legacies issues.
Of land in Africa.
That has not yet been
redistributed, for instance,
from the colonial era
honors, for instance,
is one of the root causes
of conflict in Africa.
Issues of access to resources,
access to opportunities,
for instance,
access, for instance,
to development in
Africa still very much
is an unresolved
issue of the past.
So we are using this
framework of addressing
the unresolved issues of the
past and the colonial era
legacies through
transitional justice
to ensure that we
deal with issues
of redistributive justice
through transitional justice.
We deal with the
issues, for instance,
of addressing some of the
past issues, for instance,
the high levels of inequality
in a number of African countries
really stem from
Africa's unequal past
when it comes to the
rights, the access,
and opportunities that
are available for citizens
vis a vis those available.
For instance, for colonial
masters or colonial era owners,
for instance.
Those who colonized
Africa in the past.
So we have an Africa,
where our colonial era
honors, or colonial
era masters live
alongside the majority
of Africans who are poor,
who are excluded from the
mainstream economic activity
because of the segregation
and the exclusionary laws
during colonial era.
So how do we address
some of those issues?
We really need to rethink and
relook at some of the issues,
for instance, the inequalities
brought about by colonialism
in Africa, addressing
them as some
of the root causes of
the current conflicts
that we experience in Africa.
Some of the tensions we see
in a number of countries,
for instance, are
really need us to adopt
that lens of addressing
some of these issues
through transitional
justice and addressing them
from a redistributive
justice lens.
That is one of the elements
enshrined in the African Union
Transitional Justice Policy
as an element or a pillar
of transitional
justice to address
some of these issues stemming
from Africa's brutal past.
LILIANE UMUBYEYI:
Can you give us
concrete examples
of how you are you
are mobilizing this framework
with specific countries?
ANNAH MOYO: Certainly.
Some countries, for instance,
like Namibia are currently
undertaking an audit around
the land reform agenda,
for instance.
So we are coming
in saying, there
is a need to use
transitional justice
lens to that discussion.
It cannot be simply a matter
of land expropriation.
It has to be an
issue that is looked
from a transitional
justice lens,
through risk redistributive
justice that I spoke about.
How does it look like from
a transitional justice lens?
How do we address this
as an issue of the past?
The unresolved past the
colonial era legacy in Namibia,
for instance.
That, for instance,
is causing tensions
in the current
governance in Namibia.
So having a transitional
justice lens
then will ensure that we look
at land ownership issues,
and look at, for
instance, who were
the original owners
of the land prior
before colonial colonization
and seeking then
to at least redistribute
land equally evenly
amongst the populace of Namibia.
So a transitional
justice look then
forces us, not
only to look at it
from an economic point of
view or from a land ownership
point of view, but to really
look at who are the owners.
In some instances,
colonial lands
belonging to ethnic
groups was taken.
So some of it
really will require
that we redistribute that
land to the original owners
and ensure that that
ownership of the land
to the original
settlers is retained.
But at the same time, addressing
the high levels of inequality
in the country through
transitional justice.
So with transitional
justice we are
looking at addressing or
redressing some of the wrongs--
the colonial era wrongs--
at the same time, ensuring
that we are transforming
and developing the
lives of Namibians
currently in the
current dispensation,
ensuring that issues of equity
equitable redistribution
of resources of land
and opportunities
for agriculture, for
economic development,
and economic empowerment
are distributed evenly
across races, across
ethnic groups,
ethnicity, and across
the population,
the whole population, and
the people of Namibia.
LILIANE UMUBYEYI:
Thank you very much,
and I guess it's very obvious
when you are on a continent.
And when you can see every
day like the different ways
in which colonialism
is still present
and its legacy is
still structuring
the lives of the population.
But what about-- do
you think that we
are this framework of
transitional justice
could be useful in tackling
the legacies of colonialism
in the global North, where maybe
states like here and in Belgium
could be inclined to
say it's something
which happened in the past
which belongs to the past,
it's not the present anymore.
So first of all, do you
think it's relevant,
it could be useful, and
how could it be done?
ANNAH MOYO: Thank you,
Liliane for that question.
Issues of the past
can never really
be buried with
the past, which is
why, for instance, many
former colonial countries will
be pushing for to
say it's in the past,
let's let bygones be bygones.
Let's move forward,
but really, the past--
at least in the African
continent-- continues
to haunt the present and it
also threatens the future,
for instance, because
some of those legacies
continue to be to
manifest themselves
as root causes of
current conflicts
and current manifestations
of tensions that
lead to conflict that can easily
lead to gross human rights
violations.
So definitely, we need
to revisit the past.
If you look at a country like
Germany, for instance, in 2018,
Germany developed a
transition adjusted strategy
to deal with the
past, especially
in the African
countries that were
former colonies of Germany.
Again, this was an
acknowledgment by Germany
of the fact that we cannot
really bury the past.
The past is very much present.
The only way we can move
forward and really begin
the development--
begin to give developmental
aid to some of these countries
is really by first and
foremost addressing the past,
because even though we may
say we are moving forward
collectively, but
the very communities,
the ethnic groups that
were affected by genocide,
gross human rights
violations are slavery
and many other
international crimes
that happened during
the colonial era
are very much wounded.
They are still a wounded.
The past is not in the past,
but still very much alive.
The experiences have been
passed on through generations
through narration oral
history you name it.
So communities are aware of what
happened, and therefore, when
nothing is being seen to be
done to address or redress
colonial era wrongs
or legacies or crimes,
then this fuels tensions
amongst those communities,
especially where the very
same colonial era masters come
in the name of
providing aid, providing
support and developmental
and economic support
to the very countries that they
previously committed atrocities
and wrongs to.
So that is the fuels that
tension, especially when
now you look at other
tensions, for instance,
in other fault
lines of ethnicity,
fault lines of our political
party, and association
amongst others.
So inasmuch as if a particular
president in the global South
may accept that aid, but
those who are aggrieved
or those who are
affected, if they belong
to the opposite ethnic
group, for instance,
this tends to fuel tensions
amongst community members.
And we have seen some of
these tensions becoming
a full blown conflict
or full blown wars
in some of the
countries in Africa.
Look at Angola, for instance.
Look at countries, for instance,
that are still now battling
with a lot of with a lot
of instability like Guinea
that just had a coup recently.
So these are some
of the fault lines
that usually when we
don't address the past,
then the past continues
to haunt the present
and it threatens the
stability of the future
and the sustainable peace
that we try to build
for future generations.
So there is a need to
address the past in order
to secure the
present and secure,
again, a future that is
free of violence and also
that is transformational and
leads to sustainable peace.
So what I would
say, for instance,
for countries in the
global North, especially
European countries,
Europe, for instance, developed
a transitional justice policy,
but what is a big
gap in this policy
is addressing
issues of the past?
So we are having a policy
in the European Union
that focuses on current
and future conflicts
without really addressing
issues of the past.
That, in itself, is a big gap,
because we cannot dissociate
the past and the current
occurrences of conflict in many
African countries
from the colonial era.
So there is a need for
a holistic approach
to addressing conflicts in
Africa that really go back
to the past.
The colonial era wrongs,
the colonial era legacies
that has been
unresolved until now.
And starting from
there, in order
to build a culture of
non-punity for those
who committed those
wrongs at the time,
but also for future perpetrators
of these crimes in the future,
whether they are
Africans or non Africans.
And we are seeing a
lot of proliferation,
for instance, of guns
coming from Europe, coming
from the global
North, for instance.
So even the current
conflicts, for instance,
do have a starting
point, they do
have instigators and fuelers.
So the wrong of the global
North can never really
be overlooked in the
current conflicts.
And addressing some
of these really
has to go back to the history,
go back to the colonial era
wrongs that were
committed and start
addressing them coming from the
past, coming to the present,
and then seeking also
to secure and build
a transformative,
sustainable, peaceful future.
LILIANE UMUBYEYI: Before--
thank you very much.
It's fascinating.
Before we start
this recording, we
were talking about the
technical nightmares
or technical
nightmare that we face
when we bring those crimes, the
colonial crimes into courts.
So what are the constraints of
using the transitional justice
framework, because as you or you
have said with many advantages
related to the fact that we can
tackle the roots of conflicts.
So I think in terms
of proscription,
we have more advantages.
Maybe you can develop
on that point,
but what are the constraints?
To what extent is
it really the way
through which people
have to frame or to shape
their struggles?
ANNAH MOYO: Thank you,
Liliane, for that question.
Indeed, I have alluded
to some of the advantages
and some of the opportunities
for transitional justice
to address this.
One of the biggest
opportunities I
think just before I go
into the constraints.
One of the opportunities
of transitional justice
is that there is a recognition.
For instance, when
we are dealing
with these issues through
transitional justice
that we are dealing with
an abnormal situation, that
therefore calls for
some form of flexibility
in terms of really looking
at the narrower and very
restrictive international law
and international human rights
tenets that seek to
identify a perpetrator,
seek to identify a victim,
and therefore, the perpetrator
must be brought to book and
the victim must be redressed,
but there must be reparation.
But within a transitional
justice, the higher number
of trade-offs built
within the system,
for instance, yes, perpetrators
have to be identified.
And there has to be
acknowledgment of having
committed some wrongs.
But at the same time,
the kind of justice
that we are talking about
is not perfect justice,
it is justice that comes with
a number of trade-offs, where,
for instance, sometimes
an apology can be taken
is what is needed to
redress, for instance,
or to satisfy those who
are victims reparations,
not in the true sense of
the full measure of what
the victim suffered,
but as a token
or as a symbol of
acknowledgment.
So symbolic reparations
are some of the trade-offs,
for instance.
So it's not your
perfect justice,
but it's justice that
comes with trade-offs,
but that also acknowledges
the experiences
of those who suffered and
also the perpetration of those
who may have perpetrated
the atrocities
and those coming
together coexisting
towards moving forward, being
transformed, transforming
perpetrators, and victims
into active citizens who
can live alongside each other.
Who can partner
together in order
to build a sustainable,
peaceful future.
So some of the constraints
of transitional justice, once
again, is the fact that
there may not be political
will, in most
instances, from those
who are seen to be
perpetrators, especially
for colonial era wrongs.
The states who may have
perpetrated those atrocities
may not be willing
to reopen the chapter
to look at what happened, begin
a process of truth seeking,
then identification of
perpetrators, acknowledging
that indeed wrongs
were committed
and seeking to forge a
path together with victims
towards addressing some
of these atrocities
and together achieving,
or rather building
towards achieving sustainable
peace in the long term.
So there might not be any
political will whatsoever.
And transitional justice really
relies on the political will
and willingness of
those who perpetrated
those atrocities and the
victim, or rather the countries
to whom these wrongs
were committed against.
So that is the starting point.
If this is not there, then
any transitional justice talks
will definitely fail,
because both parties
need to come to the table, need
to initiate that conversation,
and map out a
transitional justice
strategy on how this
will be addressed.
So that is number
one constraint,
and this is where,
in most countries,
even countries just where
without in the global South,
where there global
North perpetrator,
this is how many transitional
justice processes
fail because of that
lack of political will.
Another constraint that I can
bring with transitional justice
once again is just the
issue around records.
Because now, we are
talking about what
happened in the past.
Colonial era in many
African countries
means more than 50 years
of these atrocities
having been committed.
Some are committed in the 1900s.
We are in 2021, so the direct
victims have passed away.
So there was no record
keeping at the time.
So issues of record
keeping to really determine
who was a victim,
how they suffered
and all of those things.
So archives are not
available in many countries.
So really it's a word
of mouth or experiences
of victims passed on
orally by word of mouth
through generations.
So the first-hand narrative of
what happened may not exist.
Some countries have
really done well
in terms of archiving
what happened
or keeping a national collective
of what happened in the past,
but in many instances
for transitional justice,
especially when we are
looking at reparations,
a direct or rather
individual reparations,
this may not be
enough, for instance,
to secure individual
reparations for direct victims.
It may not be
enough for instance
to secure a prosecution for
those who may have committed
those atrocities.
But of course, other
international law principles
may kick in that will really
help transitional justice
processes.
For instance, the
International law principle
in international human rights
that even in instances where
those who committed
atrocities may not
be in government at the time
but the most current governments
would belong to
that specific state
inherit the crimes committed
by the previous government
so they can still
be held accountable.
They can still be
taken to court.
They can still be called
to answer or respond
to some of the questions
that may come up
around transitional justice
reparations and so forth
and they can make an apology.
They can pay
reparations to victims.
They can make
symbolic reparations.
They can come to
the party in terms
of acknowledging and
admitting the wrongs that
were committed in the past.
LILIANE UMUBYEYI:
Thank you very much.
It's very clear.
You mentioned at
some point that were
building a transitional justice
strategy with the African
Union.
So do you think it's more--
I mean on the issues of
colonial crimes more relevant
from the perspective
of African countries
to work at the regional
level rather than
at the national level?
Yeah, and how this strategic,
AU strategy, African Union,
is going to be deployed,
implement, and implemented?
ANNAH MOYO: Thank you
for that question.
So the African Union
developed the policy.
It was adopted in 2019, and one
of the issues that really it
focuses on is addressing
the colonial era
legacies in Africa.
And of course, the
policy is continental,
but it's still applying
at a national level,
for instance, for those
countries that are affected.
So the policy really
is a guideline
for member states undertaking
transitional justice processes.
So it provides a menu of
transitional justice options
that a country that is
undertaking a TJ process
can choose from in
order to address
the consequences
of past violations,
past and present violations.
So the application is still
very much at a national level,
although the strategy really
is applicable and exist
at the continental level.
So really, it's still very much
obliged at continental level.
But there are
definitely alternatives
of applying it regionally,
especially where some
of conflicts take
a regional turn
or take a regional
manifestation, for instance.
So those opportunities
exist, and in addressing
some of the regional concerns
or regional manifestations
of conflict are some of the
regional economic communities
are also now engaging taking
that continental transitional
justice policy and
developing their own regional
region-specific transitional
justice policies
or strategies to address some
of the regional contextual
realities.
So it can apply regionally.
It can also apply nationally,
but we are seeing a trend now,
where there is a regional
strategy that really seeks
to address some of
the regional realities
and experiences of conflict.
As we see with some of these
issues like violent extremism,
there is the regional
connotation to them.
So a regional
approach is much more
preferred than a national
approach that may not really
address or redress
the issues that
affect a specific region
or a number of countries
within a region.
LILIANE UMUBYEYI:
Thank you very much,
and I'm looking forward to
having a discussion with you
and the students and activists,
because I think you are you
bring a number of very
important elements
that we have to consider
when we address or think
about the possibility
of pursuing justice
for colonial crimes in
the context of Belgium.